today the council agreed its position on
the proposal for new rules on the
conservation of fishery resources and
the protection of marine ecosystems
often referred to as technical measures
the council's general approach aims at
modernizing the existing rules on how
and where fishermen may fish until now
European fishermen have had to respect
more than 30 different regulations which
constitute a particularly complex and
burdensome legislative framework we want
to make their life easier
guarantee legal certainty and focus on
innovation on the Malta meta fish
forever declaration we discussed the
significance of the declaration signed
on the 29th and 30th March in Valletta
our discussion today is also Illustrated
our commitment to actively implement the
Declaration on sustainable development
goal number 14 the sustainable use of
the oceans we discussed the ocean
conference which will be held at DeLand
in June and the other ocean conference
which will be hosted by the EU in Malta
in October and these two conferences are
the most important events for our oceans
this year